hello and welcome to this video playing
again the man yeah and he's playing the
Hedgehog most of the time not this time
maybe he gets an a shock anyway if it
let's see I can so he can play place a
benoni maybe let's play you three you
play something classical and see how he
does them know how this is Playa it but
let's see just play normal moves
probably equal if is normally considered
to be risky here let's see in this
general position type this kind of thing
can be tricky you know threatening 95
now so g6 probably it's almost almost
the only move and now 94 not sure if
this is doing that much
yeah it seems like the logical move to
claim
seems is not intended to take a bishop
at five okay maybe this one
you
yeah check it please bleach again yeah
Knight takes Knight takes Queen age for
could be something i don't really like
this situation their way I'm pinned this
looks wrong wrong
so think it's somewhat inconvenient us
to be in this pen take 94 Queenie choice
a bit annoying it feels a bit tied down
then yeah somehow I wonder if I should
play a 3 or prepare f3 like this and
then f3 I don't know Roxy age is the
thing now you might have some night
takes before something something brutal
b5 also my god yeah haha I totally miss
played this position I don't have a
single playable knew him really simple
rook c8 is just wrong I cannot even play
Queen back Jesus
yeah okay my god ah saraakiisha Pierre
down and it doesn't imply queen age four
and i'm sitting here thinking about
stuff and it's probably still good it
still has this this b5 and night before
business so I totally hate this what did
i do in this game that was really weird
we played a mistimed e5 and I'm in
trouble somehow really weird I really
think if I hi morning is a mr. move for
a while anyway it just sucks this
position
the main hope is mistakes before by
black position itself completely sucks I
should play maybe a four at some point
okay it doesn't really matter the only
way is being helped by by black with
some mistake
yeah there's very little play before is
pretty weak I don't threaten it's not
threatened much is the problem you can
yeah probably just strengthen the
position a little bit one by one move by
move can I take onee form as the pawn
that is hanging unfortunately doesn't
really matter all that much just hoping
for something here probably there is
nothing 94 might work this is this yes
covered in logistics works to check is
one of those games that they really hate
them some of you give it away for very
easily yeah white resides what did I do
that in the opening I don't really
believe you five is good I mean it just
usually just a Miss time move with
opening this and so on but I didn't
think anything I mean okay 95 seems to
be correct to get an advantage
so g5g successes okay for black young
there is no justice so I did this and
ig2g was fat I am okay yeah because I'm
not getting into a boatload of pin CRM
check here this kind of things are
better for wide so this is really a
completely annoying this position I saw
the line that the engine is giving but
as the changes like that yeah i saw this
255 and then I thought rook c8 and I
didn't really see what the point is it
just looks completely weird or what da
it may be the g3 this now I cannot go to
deform so this was the way to do it it
looks extremely shaking yeah this was
just complete nonsense yeah to just
completely idiotic move nantia this is
already already very bad computers on
just minus zero point six hours
everything is no yeah tweenage forward
sauce better of course but this is also
bad i have no move really I have
absolutely no no move here I really I
totally miss played this opening pretty
awful ok guys thanks for watching